water is vital to life on Earth and
probably to life elsewhere this has led
astronomers to become interested in
oceans
and to the discovery that oceans can be
very different to those beneath the open
skies of Earth on three of the moons of
Jupiter and two of the moons of Saturn
there is good evidence of liquid oceans
the first of these oceans to be
discovered was within Jupiter's moon
Europa though Europa is small it may
boast more liquid water than the earth
the ocean could be over a hundred
kilometers deep heat generated by
Jupiter's powerful tides keeps it warm
underneath the icy shell Europe's
Jupiter icy moons Explorer mission or
juice will launch in 2022 to study
Jupiter and three of its largest moons
perhaps one of the most promising oceans
for study is on Enceladus a tiny moon of
Saturn this is because the ocean does
not stay under the ice cap geezers at
the moon South Pole shoot ocean water
hundreds of kilometres out into space
studies by NASA's Cassini probe showed
that the water in these Jets contain
organic molecules the building blocks of
life there is also evidence of
hydrothermal vents at the bottom of the
ocean
this is significant because it is
thought that life first arose at
hydrothermal vents on earth a spacecraft
flying through the Jets of insulators
could sample the water for traces of
complex biological molecules such as DNA
or protein there is no guarantee of life
in the waters of Enceladus or in any of
the solar systems other hidden oceans
but the possibility that something might
be there we'll drive ambitious
explorations for decades to come
coming up how to discover new planets